sup Batman
[Music]
plenty go with him
obviously after I made the lego movie a
monster hit 468 million dollars
worldwide not that I'm counting of
course it seemed clear to everyone that
the world needs more of me the lego
batman movie it's a way for me to get
back to my fans with a glimpse into my
real life of fighting crime and britain
arrow is a blessing super hard under the
mask Padma prego I think it's wonderful
that the world gets to see a different
side of master Brook I mean Batman
but there's a lot more to Gotham's Dark
Knight that meets the eye for instance
did you know that Batman has recently
adopted a son camera the akhir lives up
to me in every way of course I do we are
the best team ever the idol s is need to
know it I want to be just like you when
I grow up Padre little guy wants to grow
up to be a crime-fighting vigilante
superhero just like me no matter how
dangerous and illegal it is look dad fat
dude but don't call me Dad just go to
your room okay oh I've been parented we
all know that Gotham City has a long
history of crime and my dad did a great
job cleaning things up but that was then
and this is now this movie reflects a
new Gotham City and my Gotham City hi
guys we're heroes can team up and fight
crime yep I can wear my costume too well
luckily for us you left your costume
beggarman that's perfect yeah that's due
to the studio thought my dark life of
fighting crime alone needed a few more
heroes in it even though I really don't
need anyone at any time ever because I'm
totally awesome and Batman works alone
come on Batman let's get grooving fact
is I'm a team player I said cool as long
as they don't bother me or touch any of
my stuff hey Batman I'm rubbing my butt
all over your stuff we're gonna have to
rename this the butt mobile well
obviously on fat man's greatest enemy no
matter how much he may deny it so when
the studio asked me to be the main
villain in this movie I left at the
chance to work with them again I mean
let's face it there is no Batman without
the Joker we go together like coffee and
doughnuts lapel flowers and rubber
chickens mayhem and destruction and what
I love about this movie the most is that
it finally takes the time to explore my
sensitive side I mean yes I am a master
criminal / improv comedy genius but I'm
also a nice guy and what's Batman
finally realizes this AI won't be just
smiling on the outside I'll be smiling
on the inside too that'll be a nice
relief and nobody's got a smile like you
mr. J Thank You Harley just wish Batman
with notice once in Ohio
haha love it
[Music]
this movie has everything action scenes
chase scenes building cool stuff
explosions Batman running seventh
building Batman tonicity I mean
everything it's about learning the value
of teamwork and family experience the
very emotional story of a young English
lad with a dream that he's held since
childhood to become the most popular
Butler and less famous Butler in motion
picture history it's the story of the
misunderstood criminal genius an epic
tale about one woman's bravery to
challenge a city and their hero and make
the world a better place in the end
everyone loves and respects me forever
which i think is important we're like a
bad family family might be a bit strong
I was going to say more like me and my
biggest bin or you answer awesome team
it's called the lego batman movie just
saying are you such a great padre what
are you doing I'm trying to give you a
big old hug are you were attacking me
Batman why did you build this thing with
only one speed because laughter check I
only had one but
you want to play games do you Batman 3
the city's or catch your greatest enemy
you think you might greatest enemy helps
Drive you to one-up them the way that I
do Superman so where's the bad guy I
like to fight around you seriously
saying that there is nothing special
about us there is no I never will be now
they're going to defuse that bomb
[Music]
welcome thank you Peter I'm home master
Bruce you need to take responsibility
for your life and it starts by raising
the young orphan you adopted it's the
Batcave talking a copy boy I love it I
got an idea it's better I can only look
you in the eyes right now Gotham City is
the most crime-ridden city in the world
we need to team up with Batman what
I'm back introducing the worst bones in
the history of the universe The Riddler
Catwoman yeah anguish of induced
calendar man and the condiment King are
you making some of those up nope they're
all real you guys ready just leave
gotcha
[Music]
I am so sorry soon as I get back to the
Batcave I will make sure that Alfred
puts seatbelts on there but for the time
being I'm just gonna put my arm right
here hey I'm rubbing my butt all over
you stop gonna have to rename this the
bun bo meal well she wrote what a night
what Batman works alone will never
defeat dunk alone we need to work
together go to hell too these are the
good ideas Batman has no one else has
ever had any good ideas but you can have
one diggity dog man why did you build
this thing with only one stea because
last I checked I only had one but the
lego batman movie only in cinemas
I'll first we need a king button beeps
off let's get none stop ever boys start
singing
you're my role model it must be great to
be Batman this morning ah lego batman
movie only instead of us hello family
photos I've always wanted one of those
doesn't he deserve someone to take you
under their wing you've been watching
way too many lifetime movies and
drinking Chardonnay its Pinot Grigios
whatever Batman I believe lady now your
son no that's just weird it's weird air
for tonight your son you will see is
being a part of the family again what
are you doing trying to give you a big
old hug so you're attacking me the lego
batman movie only in cinemas computer
how do I put the Joker in Arkham Asylum
quickest route no pre Weight computer do
you hear me hello suppose I've just
taken away your computer privileges yes
sir it's time for you to stop this
unhealthy behavior you can't spend the
rest of your life alone dressed in black
and staying up all night good night
Alfred burn it's morning you need to
take responsibility for your life and it
starts by raising your son I'm sorry I
literally have no idea what you're
talking about the young orphan you
adopted a cigana well I thought I was
being sarcastic hello secret camera
why
it's the fat cake oh my gosh oh my gosh
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my
gosh that man whoa your time right whoa
wait just Batman live in Bruce Wayne's
basement no Bruce Wayne lives in bed
magnetic well I'll get a copy don't
touch down the mario is culturally
infant night Karen what do we think of
it glam bad this will absolutely not
wait what's that one there I love it I
only trouble is pants for just a little
tight I got an idea rip it's better now
i'm free now i'm moving come on Batman
let's get grooving I can only look you
in the eyes right now are you ready to
follow Batman and maybe learn a few life
lessons along the way I sure AM but
first where's the seat belt the first
lesson is life doesn't give you seat
belt
Alfred I'm incredible reflexes oh oh my
goodness I am so sorry as soon as I get
back to the Batcave I will make sure
that Alfred puts seat belts on there but
for the time being I'm just gonna put my
arm right here and we're just gonna
gently he's out of here real gentle-like
yeah no I'm a computer I'm home what is
the password men in a minute and then
the Batman thank you hello
[Music]
hello again uber nerd fans I heard you
blew up the Twittersphere about my sweet
new feature film the lego batman movie
you know it's kind of like the original
lego movie only vastly superior because
it revolves entirely around me so anyway
when you're as super as me you don't get
just one trailer you get two trailers in
one week check this out
[Music]
mom hey Dad yeah hey the city again
today
I think you would have been really Brown
Hey Oh fabric I am so sorry I'm
incredible reflected I should have known
better than to sneak up on him like that
were you looking at the old family
pictures again no I wasn't sir I've seen
you go through similar sages in 2016
2012 and 2008 in 2005 in 1997 1995 in
1992 with 1989 and that weird one in
1966 I have aged phenomenally do you
want to talk about how you're feeling
what no I don't want to do that sir no
sir no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no gosh I hope we
were recording that we're not Alfred
what did I say a B are always be
recording
[Music]
in a bad man I be bad for they go with
them
you